The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: I'm going
to talk about hearing.
I gather this is the
first time in this class
that, really, people have
talked about audition.
And usually, when I
give talks and lectures,
I find it's often
helpful to just start out
by doing some listening.
So we're going to start out
this morning by just listening
to some examples of
typical auditory input
that you might encounter
during the course of your day.
So all you've got to do is just
close your eyes and listen.
Here we go.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK.
So you guys could probably
tell what all of those things
were, in case not,
here are some labels.
So the first one is just a
scene I recorded on my iPhone
in a cafe.
The second one was
something from a sports bar.
Then there was a radio excerpt,
and then some Barry White.
And the point is that
in all of those cases,
I mean, they're all
pretty different,
but in all those
cases, your brain
was inferring an awful lot about
what was happening in the world
from the sound signal that
was entering your ears.
Right?
And so what makes that kind
of amazing and remarkable
is the sensory input that it
was getting, to first order,
just looks like this.
Right?
So there was sound energy
that traveled through the air.
It was making your ear
drums wiggle back and forth
in some particular pattern
that would be indicated
by that waveform there,
that plots the pressure
at your eardrum as
a function of time.
And so from that particular
funny pattern of wiggles,
you were able to infer
all those things.
So in the case of
the cafe scene,
you could tell that there
were a few people talking.
You could probably
hear a man and a woman,
you could tell there was
music in the background.
You could hear there
was dishes clattering.
You might have been able to tell
somebody had an Irish accent.
You could probably
tell, in the sports bar,
that people were watching
football and talking about it,
and there were a
bunch of people there.
You instantly recognized
the radio excerpt
as drivetime radio, that sort
of, like, standard sound.
And in the case of
the music excerpt,
you could probably
hear six or seven,
or maybe eight
different instruments
that were each,
in their own way,
contributing to the groove.
So that's kind of
audition at work.
And so the task of the brain is
to take the sound signal that
arrives at your ears
that is then transduced
into electrical signals by your
ears, and then to interpret it
and to figure out what's
out there in the world.
So what you're interested
in, really, is not the sound
itself.
You're interested
in whether it was
a dog, or a train, or
rain, or people singing,
or whatever it was.
And so the interesting
and hard problem
that comes along with this is
that most of the properties
that we are interested
in as listeners are not
explicit in the
waveform, in the sense
that if I hand you the
sound waveform itself,
and you either look
at it, or you run sort
of standard machine
classifiers on it,
it would be very difficult to
discern the kinds of things
that you, with your brain,
can very easily just report.
And so that's really that's the
question that I'm interested in
and that our lab
studies, namely,
how is it that we derive
information about the world
from sound?
And so there's lots
of different aspects
to the problem of audition.
I'm going to give you a
taste of a few of them
over the course of
today's lecture.
A big one that lots of
people have heard about
is often known as the
cocktail party problem, which
refers to the fact that
real world settings often
involve concurrent sound.
So if you're in a room
full of busy people,
you might be trying to have a
conversation with one of them,
but there'll be lots of
other people talking,
music in the background,
and so on, and so forth.
And so from that kind of
complicated mixed signal that
enters your ears, your
brain has to estimate
the content of one particular
source of interest,
of the person that you're
trying to converse with.
So really, what you'd like
to be hearing might be this.
AUDIO: She argues
with her sister.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: But what might
enter your ear could be this.
AUDIO: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOSH MCDERMOTT: Or
maybe even this.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOSH MCDERMOTT: Or
maybe even this.
AUDIO: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOSH MCDERMOTT: So
what I've done here
plotted next to the
icons are spectrograms.
That's a way of
taking a sound signal
and turning that into an image.
So it's a plot of the
frequency content over time.
And you can see with the single
utterance up here at the top,
there's all kinds
of structure, right?
And we think that your
brain uses that structure
to understand what
was being said.
And you can see that, as more
and more people are added
to the party, that that
structure becomes progressively
more and more obscured,
until, by the time
you get to the bottom, it's kind
of amazing that you can kind
of pull anything out at all.
And yet, as you hopefully
heard, your brain
has this remarkable ability
to attend to and understand
the speech signal of interest.
And this is an ability
that still, to this day,
is really unmatched by machines.
So present day speech
recognition algorithms
are getting better
by the minute,
but this particular
problem is still
quite a significant challenge.
And you've probably
encountered this
when you try to talk to your
iPhone when you're in a car
or wherever else.
Another kind of interesting
complexity in hearing
is that sound interacts with
the environment on its way
to your ears.
So, you know, you
typically think of yourself
as listening to,
say, a person talking
or to some sound source, but
in reality, what's happening
is something like
this picture here.
So there's a speaker
in the upper right
corner from which
sound is emanating,
but the sound takes a whole lot
of different paths on its way
to your ears.
There's the direct path,
which is shown in green,
but then there are
all these other paths
where it can reflect off
of the walls in the room.
So the blue lines
here indicate paths
where there's a
single reflection.
And the red lines
indicate paths where
there are two
reflections, and so you
can see there's a lot of them.
And so the
consequence of this is
that your brain gets
all these delayed
copies of the source signal.
And what that amounts to is
really massive distortion
of the signal.
And this is known
as reverberation.
So this is dry speech.
Of course, you're hearing
this in this auditorium
that itself has lots
of reverberation,
so you're not actually
going to hear it dry,
but you'll still be able
to hear a difference.
AUDIO: They ate the lemon pie.
Father forgot the bread.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: And
this is that signal
with lots of
reverberation added,
as though you were listening to
it in a cathedral or something.
Of course, you're, again,
hearing it in this room,
as well.
AUDIO: They ate the lemon pie.
Father forgot the bread.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: And you can
still hear a difference.
And if the reverb in this
auditorium is swamping that,
you can just look
at the waveforms.
And you can see that the
waveforms of those two signals
look pretty
dramatically different,
as do the spectrograms.
All right?
So the point is
that the consequence
of all of those
delayed reflections
massively distorts
the signal, all right?
Physically, there are two
really different things
in those two cases.
But again, your ability to
recognize what's being said
is remarkably invariant to the
presence of that reverberation.
And again, this is an
instance where humans really
are outperforming machines
to a considerable extent.
This graph is a
little bit dated.
This is from, I think,
three years ago,
but it's a plot of five
different speech recognition
algorithms.
And the percent
of errors they're
making when given
a speech signal
is a function of the
amount of reverberation.
And so zero means that
there's no reverberation.
That's the dry case, right?
And so speech recognition works
pretty well without any reverb.
But when you add a little
bit of reverberation,
and this is measured in terms
of the reverberation time,
it's the amount of time
that it takes the reverb
to fall off by a certain
specified amount,
and 300 and 500 milliseconds
are actually very, very modest.
So in this auditorium,
my guess would
be that the reverberation time
is maybe even a couple seconds.
So this is, like, what you get
in a small classroom, maybe.
Maybe even less than that.
But you can see that it causes
major problems for speech
recognition.
And it's because the
information in the speech signal
gets blurred out over
time, and again, it's
just massive distortion.
So your brain is doing
something pretty complicated
in order for you to be
so robust to the presence
of the reverberation.
So I run a research
group where we
study these kinds of problems.
It's called the Lab for
Computational Addition
in the Department of Brain
and Cognitive Sciences at MIT.
We operate at the
intersection of psychology,
and neuroscience,
and engineering,
where what we aspire
to do is to understand
how it is that people hear so
well in computational terms
that would allow us
to instantiate them
in algorithms that we might
replicate in machines.
And so the research
that we try to do
involves hopefully
symbiotic relationships
between experiments in
humans, auditory neuroscience,
and machine algorithms.
And the general
approach that we take
is to start with what the
brain has to work with.
And by that, I mean we try
to work with representations
like the ones that are in
the early auditory system.
And so here's the
plan for this morning.
And this is subject
to change, depending
on what kind of feedback
I get from you guys.
But my general plan
was to start out
with an overview of
the auditory system,
because I gather there's sort
of a diversity of backgrounds
here, and nobody's talked
about audition so far.
So I was going to go
through a little overview.
And then there's been
a special request
to talk about some
texture perception.
I gather that there
were some earlier
lectures on visual texture, and
that might be a useful thing
to talk about.
It's also a nice way to
understand auditory models
a little bit better.
I was then going to talk a
little bit about the perception
of individual sound sources
and sort of the flip side
to sound texture,
and then conclude
with a section on
auditory scene analysis,
so what your brain
is able to do when
it gets a complicated sound
signal like you would get
normally in the world,
that has contributions
from multiple causes and
you have to infer those.
OK.
And so we'll take a break
about halfway through,
as I guess that's
kind of standard.
And I'm happy for people to
interrupt and ask questions.
OK.
So the general outline
for hearing, right,
is that sound is created when
objects in the world vibrate.
Usually, this is because
something hits something else,
or in the case of a
biological organism,
there is some energy
imparted to the vocal cords.
And the object vibrates.
That vibration gets transmitted
to the air molecules around it,
and you get a sound wave
that travels through the air.
And that sound wave then
gets measured by the ears.
And so the ear is a
pretty complicated device
that is designed
to measure sound.
It's typically divided
up into three pieces.
So there's the outer
ear, consisting
of the pinna and the eardrum.
In functional terms,
people usually
think about this as a
directional microphone.
There's the middle ear.
They're these three little
bones in between the eardrum
and the cochlea
that are typically
ascribed the functions of
impedance matching and overload
protection.
I'm not going to talk
about that today.
And then there's the inner
ear that the cochlea,
which in very coarse
engineering terms,
we think of as doing some
kind of frequency analysis.
And so again, at
kind of a high level,
so you've got your ears here.
This is the inner
ear on each side.
And then those send feedforward
input to the midbrain,
and there's a few different
way stations here.
The cochlear nucleus is
superior olivery complex,
the inferior colliculus, and
then the mediagenic nucleus
or the thalamus.
And the thalamus then projects
to the auditory cortex.
And there's a couple
things at a high level
that are worth noting here.
One is that the pathways
here are actually
pretty complicated, especially
relative to the visual system
that you guys have been
hearing lots about it.
Right?
So there's a bunch of different
stops on the way to the cortex.
Another interesting thing is
that input from the two ears
gets mixed at a
pretty early stage.
OK.
All right, so let's
step back and talk
about the cochlea for a moment.
And I realize that
some of you guys
will know about
this stuff, so we'll
go through it kind of quick.
Now one of the
signature features
of cochlear transduction is
that its frequency tunes.
So this is an unwrapped
version of the cochlea.
So if we step back
to here, all right--
so we've got the outer ear,
the ear canal, the eardrum,
those three little bones
that I told you about that
connect to the cochlea.
And the cochlea is this thing
that looks like a snail.
And then if we unroll that
snail and look at it like this,
you can see that
the cochlea consists
of these tubes
separated by a membrane.
The membrane is called
the basilar membrane.
That's worth knowing about.
So sound enters here at the base
and sets up a traveling wave
along this membrane.
So this is really a
mechanical thing that happens.
So there's actually,
like, a physical vibration
that occurs in this membrane.
And it's a wave that
travels along the cochlea.
And one of the signature
discoveries about the cochlea
is that that traveling wave
peaks in different places,
depending on the frequency
content of the sound.
And that's schematized in these
drawings here on the right.
So if the ear were to receive
a high frequency sound,
that traveling wave
would peak near the base.
If it were to receive a
medium frequency sound,
the wave would peak
somewhere in the middle.
And a low frequency sound
would peak near the apex.
And the frequency tuning, it's
partly mechanical in origin,
so that membrane, it varies
in thickness and stiffness
along its length.
And there's also a contribution
that's non-linear and active,
that we'll talk briefly
about it in a little bit.
So this is a close up.
This is a cross-section.
So imagine you took this
diagram and you kind of cut it
in the middle.
This is a cross-section
of the cochlea.
So this here is the
basilar membrane,
and this is the organ
of Corti that sits
on top of the basilar membrane.
And so if you look
closely, you can
see that there's
this thing in here.
This is the inner hair cell.
And that's the guy that
does the transduction that
takes the mechanical energy
that's coming from the fact
that this thing is
vibrating up and down,
and turns that into an
electrical signal that
gets sent to your brain.
And so the way
that that works is
that there is this
other membrane here
called the tectorial membrane.
And the hair cells got these
cilia that stick out of it.
And as it moves up
and down, there's
a shearing that's created
between the two membranes.
The hair cell body deforms,
and that deformation
causes a change in its
membrane potential.
And that causes
neurotransmitter to be released.
All right, so
that's the mechanism
by which the brain takes
that mechanical signal
and turns it into an
electrical signal that
gets sent to your brain.
The other thing to note here,
and we'll return to this,
is that there are these
other three cells here
that are labeled as
outer hair cells.
And so those kind of
do what the inner hair
cell does in reverse.
So they get an electrical
signal from your brain,
and that causes the hair
cell bodies to deform,
and that actually alters the
motion of the basilar memory.
So it's like a
feedback system that we
believe serves to amplify sounds
and to sharpen their tuning.
So there's feedback all
the way to the all the way
to the cochlea.
OK.
So this is just another view.
So here's the inner
hair cell here.
As this thing
vibrates up and down,
there's a shearing
between these membranes.
The inner hair cell
membrane potential changes,
and that causes
neurotransmitter release.
OK, and so here's the
really important point.
So we just talked about
how there's this traveling
wave that gets set up that
peaks in different places,
depending on the frequency
content of the sound.
And so because to
first order only,
part of the basilar
membrane moves
for a given frequency
of sound, each hair cell
and the auditory nerve
fiber that it synopsis with,
signals only particular
frequencies of sound.
And so this is sort of the
classic textbook figure
that you would
see on this, where
what's being plotted
on the y-axis
is the minimum sound
intensity needed
to elicit a neural response.
And the x-axis is the frequency
of a tone with which you
would be stimulating the ear.
So we have a little
pure tone generator
with a knob that allows you
to change the frequency,
and another knob that allows
you to change the level.
And you sit there recording
from an auditory nerve fiber,
varying the frequency, and then
turning the level up and down
until you get spikes
out of the nerve fiber.
And so for every
nerve fiber, there
will be some frequency called
the characteristic frequency,
at which you can
elicit spikes when
you present the sound
at a fairly low level.
And then as you
change the frequency,
either higher or
lower, the level
that is needed to
elicit a response grows.
And so you can think of
this as like a tuning curve
for that auditory nerve fiber.
All right?
And different nerve fibers
have different characteristic
frequencies.
Here is just a picture that
shows a handful of them.
And so together, collectively,
they kind of tile the space.
And of course, given
what I just told you,
you can probably guess that
each of these nerve fibers
would synapse to a different
location along the cochlea.
The ones that have high
characteristic frequencies
would be near the base.
The ones that have low
characteristic frequencies
would be near the apex.
OK.
So in computational terms, the
common way to think about this
is to approximate auditory nerve
fibers with bandpass filters.
And so this would
be the way that you
would do this in a model.
Each of these curves
is a bandpass filter,
so what you see on the y-axis
is the response of the filter.
The x-axis is frequency.
So each filter has some
particular frequency
at which they give
a peak response,
and then the signal
is attenuated
on either side of
that peak frequency.
And so one way to think about
what the cochlea is doing
to the signal is that it's
taking the signal that
enters the ears, this
thing here-- so this
is just a sound signal,
so the amplitude just
varies over time in
some particular way.
You take that
signal, you pass it
through this bank
of bandpass filters,
and then the output of
each of these filters
is a filtered version
of the original signal.
And so in engineering terms,
we call that a subband.
So this would be the result
of taking that sound signal
and filtering it
with a filter that's
tuned to relatively low
frequencies, 350 to 520
Hertz, in this particular case.
And so you can see that
the output of that filter
is a signal that varies
relatively slowly.
So it wiggles up
and down, but you
can see that the wiggles are
in some sort of confined space
of frequencies.
If we go a little
bit further up,
we get the output
of something that's
tuned to slightly
higher frequencies.
And you can see that the
output of that filter
is wiggling at a faster rate.
And then if we go
up further still,
we get a different thing, that
is again wiggling even faster.
And so collectively, we can take
this original broadband signal,
and then represent it with a
whole bunch of these subbands.
Typically, you might
use 30, or 40, or 50.
So one thing to
note here, you might
have noticed that
there's something
funny about this picture and
that the filters, here, which
are indicated by these colored
curves, are not uniform.
Right?
So the ones down
here are very narrow,
and the ones down
here are very broad.
And that's not an accident.
That's roughly what you
find when you actually
look in the ear.
And why things are
that way is something
that you could
potentially debate.
But it's very
clear, empirically,
that that's roughly
what you find.
I'm not going to say too
much more about this now,
but remember that
because it will
become important a
little bit later on.
So we can take these
filters, and turn that
into an initial stage of an
auditory model, the stuff
that we think is happening
in the early auditory system
where we've got our
sound signal that
gets passed through this
bag of bandpass filters.
And you're now
representing that signal
as a bunch of different
subbands, just two of which
are shown here for clarity.
And the frequency selectivity
that you find in the ear
has a whole host of
perceptual consequences.
I won't go through all
of them exhaustively.
It's one of the main
deterrents of what masks what.
So for instance,
when you're trying
to compress a sound signal
by turning it into an mp3,
you have to really pay attention
to the nature of these filters.
And, you know, you don't
need to represent parts
of the filters that would be--
sorry, parts of the
signal would be masked,
and these filters tell
you a lot about that.
One respect in which frequency
selectivity is evident
is by the ability to hear
out individual frequency
components of sounds that have
lots of frequencies in them.
So this is kind of a
cool demonstration.
And to kind of help us
see what's going on,
we're going to look at
a spectrogram of what's
coming in.
So hopefully this will work.
So what this little
thing is doing is
there's a microphone
in the laptop,
and it takes that
microphone signal
and turns it into a spectrogram.
It's using a logarithmic
frequency scale here,
so it goes from about
100 Hertz up to 6400.
And so if I don't
say anything, you'll
be able to hear the room
noise, or see the room noise.
All right, so
that's the baseline.
And also, the
other thing to note
is that the microphone doesn't
have very good bass response.
And so the very low
frequencies won't show up.
But everything else will.
OK.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Canceled harmonics.
A complex tone is
presented, followed
by several cancellations
and restorations
of a particular harmonic.
This is done for
harmonics 1 through 10.
[LOUD TONE]
[TONE]
END PLAYBACK]
OK.
And just to be clear,
the point of this, right,
is that what's happening here--
just stop that for a second--
is you're hearing what's
called a complex tone.
That just means a tone that
has more than one frequency.
All right?
That's what
constitutes complexity
for a psychoacoustician.
So it's a complex tone.
And each of the stripes, here,
is one of the frequencies.
So this is a harmonic complex.
Notice that the fundamental
frequency is 200 Hertz,
and so all the other frequencies
are integer multiples of that.
So there's 400, 600, 800, 1,000
1200, and so on, and so forth.
OK?
Then what's happening is
that in each little cycle
of this demonstration,
one of the harmonics
is getting pulsed on and off.
All right?
And the consequence of it
being pulsed on and off
is that you're able to
actually hear it as, like,
a distinct thing.
And the fact that that
happens, that's not, itself,
happening in the ear.
That's something
complicated and interesting
that your brain is doing
with that signal it's
getting from the ear.
But the fact you're
able to do that
is only possible by
virtue of the fact
that the signal that your
brain gets from the ear
divides the signal up in a
way that kind of preserves
the individual frequencies.
All right?
And so this is just a
demonstration that you're
actually able to, under
appropriate circumstances,
to hear out particular
frequency components
of this complicated thing, even
if you just heard it by itself,
it would just sound
like one thing.
So another kind of interesting
and cool phenomenon
that is related to
frequency selectivity
is the perception of beating.
So how many people here
know what beating is?
Yeah, OK.
So beating is a
physical phenomenon
that happens whenever you have
multiple different frequencies
that are present
at the same time.
So in this case, those are
the red and blue curves
up at the top.
So those are sinusoids of
two different frequencies.
And the consequence of them
being two different frequencies
is that over time, they
shift in and out of phase.
And so there's this
particular point here
where the peaks of the
waveforms are aligned,
and then there's this point
over here where the peak of one
aligns with the
trough of the other.
It's just because they're
two different frequencies
and they slide in
and out of phase.
And so when you play those two
frequencies at the same time,
you get the black
waveform, so some linearly.
That's what sounds do when
they're both present at once.
And so the point at
which the peaks align,
there is constructive
interference.
And the point at which the
peak and the trough align,
there is destructive
interference.
And so over time, the
amplitude waxes and wanes.
And so physically, that's
what's known as beating.
And the interesting thing
is that the audibility
of the beating is very tightly
constrained by the cochlea.
So here's one frequency.
[TONE]
Here's the other.
And then you play
them at the same time.
[TONE]
Can you hear that fluttering
kind of sensation?
All right.
So that's amplitude modulation.
OK.
And so I've just
told you how we can
think of the cochlea
as this set of filters,
and so it's an interesting
empirical fact that you only
hear beating if the two
frequencies that are beating
fall roughly within the
same cochlear bandwidth.
OK?
And so when they're pretty close
together, like, one semi-tone,
the beating is very audible.
[TONE]
But as you move them further
apart-- so three semi-tones
is getting close to, roughly,
what a typical cochlear filter
bandwidth would be, and the
beating is a lot less audible.
[TONE]
And then by the time you
get to eight semi-tones,
you just don't hear anything.
It just sounds like two tones.
[TONE]
Very clear.
So contrast that with--
[TONE]
All right.
So the important thing to
emphasize is that in all three
of these cases, physically,
there's beating happening.
All right?
So if you actually were to look
at what the eardrum was doing,
you would see the
amplitude modulation here,
but you don't hear that.
So this is just another
consequence of the way
that you're cochlea
is filtering sound.
OK.
All right, so we've got
our auditory model, here.
What happens next?
So there's a couple of
important caveats about this.
And I mentioned this, in part,
because some of these things
are--
we don't really know exactly
what the true significance
is of some of these
things, especially
in computational terms.
So I've just told you
about how we typically
will model with the
cochlea is doing
as a set of linear
bandpass filters.
So you get a signal, you
apply a linear filter,
you get a subband.
But in actuality,
if you actually
look at what the
ear is doing, it's
pretty clear that
linear filtering
provides only an approximate
description of cochlear tuning.
And in particular,
this is evident
when you change sound levels.
So what this is a plot
of is tuning curves
that you would measure from
an auditory nerve fiber.
So we've got spikes per
second on the y-axis,
we've got the frequency
of a pure tone stimulus
on the x-axis, and
each curve plots
the response at a different
stimulus intensity.
All right?
So down here at
the bottom, we've
got 35 dB SPL, so that's, like,
a very, very low level, like,
maybe if you rub your hands
together or something, that
would be close to 35.
And 45-- and you can
see here that the tuning
is pretty narrow here
at these low levels.
So 45 dB SPL.
So you get a pretty
big response, here,
at looks like, you
know, 1700 Hertz.
And then by the time you go down
half an octave or something,
there's almost no response.
But as the stimulus
level increases,
you can see that the
tuning broadens really
very considerably.
And so up here at 75 or 85
dB, you're getting a response
from anywhere from 500 Hertz out
to, you know, over 2,000 Hertz.
That's, like, a two
octave range, right?
So the bandwidth is growing
pretty dramatically.
And this is very typical.
Here is a bunch of examples
of different nerve fibers
that are doing the same thing.
So at high levels, the
tuning is really broad.
At low levels, it's
kind of narrow.
And so mechanistically,
in terms of the biology,
we have a pretty
good understanding
of why this is happening.
So what's going on is
that the outer hair cells
are providing amplification
of the frequencies kind
of near the characteristic
frequency of the nerve fiber
at low levels, but
not at high levels.
And so at high levels,
what you're seeing
is just very broad kind
of mechanical tuning.
But what really sort
of remains unclear is
what the consequences of this
are for hearing, and really,
how to think about it
in computational terms.
So it's clear that the
linear filtering view is not
exactly right.
And one of the
interesting things
is that it's not like you
get a lot worse at hearing
when you go up to 75 or 85 dB.
In fact, if anything, most
psychophysical phenomena,
actually, are better
in some sense.
This phenomena, as
I said, is related
to this distinction between
inner hair cells and outer hair
cells.
So the inner hair
cells are the ones
that, actually, are responsible
for the transduction
of sound energy, and the outer
hair cells we think of as part
of a feedback system
that amplifies
the motion of the membrane
and sharpens at the tuning.
And that amplification is
selective for frequencies
at the characteristic
frequency, and really occurs
at very low levels.
OK.
So this is related to
what Hynek was mentioning
and the question that
was asked earlier.
So there's this other
important response property
of the cochlea, which is
that for frequencies that
are sufficiently low,
auditory nerve spikes are
phase locked to the stimulus.
And so what you're seeing
here is a single trace
of a recording from a
nerve fiber that's up top,
and then at the
bottom is the stimulus
that would be supplied
to the air, which
is just a pure tone of
some particular frequency.
And so you can note, like,
two interesting things
about this response.
The first is that the
spikes are intermittent.
You don't get a spike at
every cycle of the frequency.
But when the spikes occur--
sorry, they occur at
a particular phase
relative to the stimulus.
Right?
So they're kind of
just a little bit
behind the peak of the waveform
in this particular case, right,
and in every single case.
All right, so this is
known as phase locking.
And it's a pretty robust
phenomena for frequencies
under a few kilohertz.
And this is in
non-human animals.
There's no measurements of
the auditory nerve in humans
because to do so
is highly invasive,
and just nobody's ever done
it, and probably won't ever.
So this is another example
of the same thing, where
again, this is sort
of the input waveform,
and this is a bunch of different
recordings of the same nerve
fiber that are time aligned.
So you can see the
spikes always occur
at a particular
region of phase space.
So they're not
uniformly distributed.
And the figure here
on the right shows
that this phenomenon
deteriorates
at very high frequency.
So this is the plot of the
strength of the phase locking
as a function of frequency.
And so up to a kilohertz,
it's quite strong,
and then it starts to kind of
drop off, and above about 4k
there's not really a whole lot.
OK.
And so as I said, one of
the other salient things
is that the fibers don't
fire with every cycle
of the stimulus.
And one interesting
fact about the ear
is that there are a whole
bunch of auditory nerve fibers
for every inner hair cell.
And people think that one
of the reasons for that
is because of this
phenomena, here.
And this is probably due to
things like refractory periods
and stuff, right?
But if you have a whole bunch
of nerve fibers synapsing
under the same
hair cell, the idea
is that, well, collectively,
you'll get spikes
at every single cycle.
So here's just some
interesting numbers.
So the number of inner hair
cells per ear in a human
is estimated to be about 3500.
There's about four times
as many outer hair cells,
or roughly 12,000, but
that's the key number here.
So coming out of every ear are
roughly 30,000 auditory nerve
fibers.
So there's about 10 times as
many auditory nerve fibers
as there are inner hair cells.
And it's interesting to
compare those numbers
to what you see in the eye.
So these are estimates
from a few years
ago, from the eye of roughly
5 million cones per eye,
lots of rods, obviously.
But then you go to
the optic nerve,
and the number of
optic nerve fibers
is actually substantially
less than the number of cones.
So 1 and 1/2 million.
So there's this big
compression that
happens when you go into
the auditory nerve--
sorry, in the optic
nerve, whereas there's
an expansion that happens
in the auditory nerve.
And just for fun, these
are rough estimates
of what you find in the cortex.
So in primary
auditory cortex, this
is a very crude estimate
I got from someone
a couple of days ago, of 60
million neurons per hemisphere.
And in v1, the estimate
that I was able to find
was 140 million.
So these are sort of roughly
the same order of magnitude,
although it's obviously
smaller in the auditory system.
But there is something
very different
happening here, in terms of the
way the information is getting
piped from the periphery
onto the brain.
And one reason for
this might just
be the fact that
phenomena here, where
the spiking in an individual
auditory nerve fiber
is going to be intermittent
because the signals
that it has to convey
are very, very fast,
and so you kind of have
to multiplex in this way.
All right, so the
big picture here
is that if you look at
the output of the cochlea,
there are, in some
sense, two cues
to the frequencies that
are contained in a sound.
So there's what is often
referred to as the place
of excitation in the cochlea.
So these are the
nerve fibers that
are firing the most,
according to a rate code.
And there's also the
timing of the spikes that
are fired, in the sense that,
for frequencies below about 4k,
you get phase locking.
And so the inner
spiked intervals
will be stereotyped, depending
on the frequencies that
come in.
And so it's one
of these sort of--
I still find this
kind of remarkable
when I sort of
step back and think
about the state of
things, that this
is a very basic question about
neural coding at the very
front end of the system.
And the importance
of these things
really remains unresolved.
So people have been debating
this for a really long time,
and we still don't really
have very clear answers
to the extent to which
the spike timing really
is critical for
inferring frequency.
So I'm going to play you
a demo that provides--
it's an example of some of
the circumstantial evidence
for the importance
of phase locking.
And broadly speaking,
the evidence
for the importance of
phase locking in humans
comes from the fact that
the perception of frequency
seems to change once you
kind of get above about 4k.
So for instance,
if you give people
a musical interval,
[SINGING] da da, and then
you ask them to replicate that,
in, say, different octaves,
people can do that pretty well
until you get to about 4k.
And above 4k, they
just break down.
They become very,
very highly variable.
And that's evident in
this demonstration.
So what you're going
to hear in this demo,
and this is a demonstration
I got from Peter Cariani.
Thanks to him.
It's a melody that is probably
familiar to all of you that's
being played with pure tones.
And it will be
played repeatedly,
transposed from very
high frequencies down in,
I don't know, third
octaves or something,
to lower and lower frequencies.
And what you will
experience is that when
you hear the very high
frequencies, well, A,
they'll be kind of annoying,
so just bear with me,
but the melody will
also be unrecognizable.
And so it'll only be when
you get below a certain point
that you'll say, aha,
I know what that is.
OK?
And again, we can look at
this in our spectrogram, which
is still going.
And you can actually
see what's going on.
[MELODIC TONES]
OK.
So by the end,
hopefully everybody
recognized what that was.
So let's just talk
briefly about how
these subbands that we
were talking about earlier
relate to what we see
in the auditory nerve,
and again, this relates to
one of the earlier questions.
So the subband is
this blue signal here.
This is the output
of a linear filter.
And one of the ways to
characterize a subband
like this that's band limited is
by the instantaneous amplitude
and the instantaneous phase.
And these things,
loosely, can be
mapped onto a spike
rate and spike
timing in the auditory nerve.
So again, this is an example of
the phase locking that you see,
where the spikes get fired
at some particular point
in the waveform.
And so if you
observe this, well,
you know something about
exactly what's happening
in the waveform, namely,
you know that there's energy
there in the stimulus because
you're getting spikes,
but you also actually know
the phase of the waveform
because the spikes are
happening in particular places.
And so this issue of phase
is sort of a tricky one,
because it's often not
something that we really
know how to deal with.
And it's also just
empirically the case
that a lot of the information
in sound is carried by the way
that frequencies are
modulated over time,
as measured by the instantaneous
amplitude in a subband.
And so the
instantaneous amplitude
is measured by a quantity
called the envelope.
So that's the red
curve, here, that
shows how the amplitude
waxes and wanes.
And the envelope is easy to
extract from auditory nerve
response, just by computing
the firing rate over local time
windows.
And in signal processing
terms, we typically extract it
with something called
the Hilbert transform,
by taking the magnitude
of the analytic signal.
So it's a pretty easy
thing to pull out
in MATLAB, for instance.
So just to relate this to stuff
that may be more familiar,
the spectrograms that
people have probably
seen in the past--
again, these are
pictures that take
a sound waveform
and plot the frequency
content over time.
One way to get a
spectrogram is to have
a bank of bandpass filters,
to get a bunch of subbands,
and then to extract the
envelope of each subband,
and just plot the envelope
in grayscale, horizontally.
All right?
So a stripe through this picture
is the envelope in grayscale.
So it's black in
the places where
the energy is high, and white
in the places where it's low.
And so this is a
spectrogram of this.
[DRUMMING]
All right, so that's
what you just heard.
It's just a drum break.
And you can probably
see that there
are sort of events in the
spectrogram that correspond
to things like the drumbeats.
Now, one of the other striking
things about this picture
is it looks like a mess, right?
I mean, you listen
to that drum break
and it sounded kind
of crisp and clean,
and when you actually look at
the instantaneous amplitude
in each of the subbands, it just
sort of looks messy and noisy.
But one interesting fact is that
this picture, for most signals,
captures all of the information
that matters perceptually
in the following sense, that
if you have some sound signal
and you let me
generate this picture,
and all you let me
keep is that picture.
We throw out the
original sound waveform.
From that picture,
I can generate
a sound signal that will
sound just like the original.
All right?
And in fact, I've done this.
And here is a reconstruction
from that picture.
[DRUMMING]
Here's the original.
Sounded exactly the same.
OK?
And so-- and I'll tell you
in a second, how we do this,
but the fact that this picture
looks messy and noisy is,
I think, mostly
just due to the fact
that your brain is not used
to getting the sensory input
in this format.
Right?
You're used to hearing as sound.
And so your visual system is
actually not optimally designed
to interpret a spectrogram.
I want to just briefly explain
how you take this picture
and generate a sound
signal because this
is sort of a useful
thing to understand,
and it will become relevant
a little bit later.
So the general game
that we play here
is you hand me this
picture, right,
and I want to
synthesize a signal.
And so usually what we do, is we
start out with a noise signal,
and we transform that noise
signal until it's in kind
of the right representation.
So we split it up
into its subbands.
And then we'll replace the
envelopes of the noise subbands
by the envelopes
from this picture.
OK?
And so the way
that we do that is
we measure the envelope
of each noise subband,
we divide it out, and then
we multiply by the envelope
of the thing that we want.
And that gives us new subbands.
And we then add those up, and
we get a new sound signal.
And for various reasons,
this is a process
that needs to be iterated.
So you take that
new sound signal,
you generate its subbands,
you replace their envelopes
by the ones you want,
and you add them back up
to get a sound signal.
And if you do this about 10
times, what you end up with
is something that has the
envelopes that you want.
And so then you
can listen to it.
And that's the thing
that I played you.
OK?
So it's this iterative
procedure, where you typically
start with noise, you
project the signal
that you want onto the noise,
collapse, and then iterate.
OK.
And we'll see some more
examples of this in action.
So I just told you how the
instantaneous amplitude
in each of the filter
outputs, which we characterize
with the envelope,
is an important thing
for sound representation.
And so in the auditory model
that I'm building here,
we've got a second
stage of processing
now, where we've
taken the subbands
and we extract the
instantaneous amplitude.
And there's one other thing
here that I'll just mention,
which is that another important
feature of the cochlea
is what's known as
amplitude compression.
So the response of the cochlea
as a function of sound level
is not linear, rather
it's compressive.
And this is due to
the fact that there
is selective amplification
when sounds are quiet,
and not when they're
very high in intensity.
And I'm not going
to say anything
more about this for now, but
it will become important later.
And this is something that has
a lot of practical consequences.
So when people
lose their hearing,
one of the common
things that happens
is that the outer hair cells
stop working correctly.
And the outer hair cells are
one of the things that generates
that compressive response.
So they're the
nonlinear component
of processing in the cochlea.
And so when people
lose their hearing,
the tuning both broadens,
and you get a linear response
to sound amplitude
because you lose
that selective
amplification, and that's
something that hearing
aids try to replicate,
and that's hard to do.
OK.
So what happens next?
So everybody here--
does everybody here
know what a spike
triggered average is?
Yeah.
Lots of people talked
about this, probably.
OK.
So one of the standard
ways that we investigate
sensory systems, when
we have some reason
to think that things might
be reasonably linear,
is by measuring something called
a spike triggered average.
And so the way this
experiment might work
is you would play
stimulus like this.
[NOISE SIGNAL]
So that's a type
of a noise signal.
Right?
So you'd play your
animal that signal, you'd
be recording spikes
from a neuron
that you might be interested in,
and every time there's a spike,
you would look back at
what happens in the signal
and then you would take all
the little histories that
preceded that spike.
You'd average them together,
and you get the average stimulus
that preceded a spike.
And so in this
particular case, we're
going to actually do this in
the domain of the spectrogram.
And that's because you might
hypothesize that, really,
what the neurons
would care about would
be the instantaneous
amplitude in the sound signal,
and not necessarily the phase.
So if you do that, for instance,
in the inferior colliculus,
the stage of the
midbrain, you see things
that are pretty stereotyped.
And we're going to
refer to what we get out
of this procedure as a
spectrotemporal receptive
field.
And that would often be
referred to as a STRF for short.
So if you hear people talk about
STRFs, this is what they mean.
OK.
So these are
derived from methods
that would be like the
spike triggered average.
People don't usually actually
do a spike triggered average
for various reasons, but
what you get out is similar.
And so what you see here is
the average spectrogram that
would be preceding a spike.
And for this
particular neuron, you
can see there's a bit of
red and then a bit of blue.
And so at this particular
frequency, which, in this case,
is something like 10 kilohertz
or something like that,
the optimal stimulus that
would generate a spike
is something that gives you an
increase in energy, and then
a decrease.
And so what this corresponds
to is amplitude modulation
at a particular rate.
And so you can see there's a
characteristic timing here.
So the red thing has
a certain duration,
and then there's the blue thing.
And so there is this
very rapid increase
and decrease in energy at
that particular frequency.
So that's known as
amplitude modulation.
And so this is
one way of looking
at this in the domain
of the spectrogram.
Another way of
looking at this would
be to generate a tuning function
as a function of the modulation
rate.
So you could actually
change how fast
the amplitude is
being modulated,
and you would see in
a neuron like this,
that the response
would exhibit tuning.
And so each one of
the graphs here,
or each one of the
plots, the dashed
curves in the lower right
plot-- so each dashed line is
a tuning curve for one neuron.
So it's a plot of the
response of that neuron
as a function of the temporal
modulation frequencies.
So that's how fast the
amplitude is changing with time.
And if you look at this
particular case here,
you can see that there's a peak
response when the modulation
frequency is maybe 70
Hertz, and then the response
decreases if you go
in either direction.
This guy here has got a slightly
lower preferred frequency,
and down here, lower still.
And so again, what
you can see is
something that looks strikingly
similar to the kinds of filter
banks that we just saw when we
were looking at the cochlea.
But there's a key
difference here, right,
that here we're seeing tuning
to modulation frequency,
not to audio frequency.
So this is the rate at
which the amplitude changes.
That's the amplitude of the
sound, not the audio frequency.
So there's a carrier
frequency here, which is 10k,
but the frequency we're
talking about here
is the rate at
which this changes.
And so in this
case here, you can
see the period here is maybe
5 milliseconds, and so this
would correspond to a modulation
of, I guess, 200 Hertz.
Is that right?
I think that's right.
Yeah.
OK.
And so as early as the midbrain,
you see stuff like this.
So in the inferior colliculus,
there's lots of it.
And so this suggests a
second, or in this case,
a third stage of processing,
which are known as modulation
filters.
This is a very old idea
in auditory science
that now has a fair bit
of empirical support.
And so the idea is
that in our model,
we've got our sound signal.
It gets passed through this
bank of bandpass filters,
you get these
subbands, you extract
the instantaneous amplitude,
known as the envelope,
and then you take that
envelope and you pass it
through another filter bank.
This time, these
are filters that are
tuned in modulation frequency.
And the output of
those filters-- again,
it's exactly conceptually
analogous to the output
of this first set of
band pass filters.
So in this case,
we have a filter
that's tuned to low
modulation rates,
and so you can see what
it outputs is something
that's fluctuating very slowly.
So it's just taken the
very slow fluctuations
out of that envelope.
Here, you have a filter
that's tuned to higher rates,
and so it's wiggling
around at faster rates.
And you have a different
set of these filters
for each cochlear channel,
each thing coming out
of the cochlea.
So this picture here that
we've gradually built up
gives us a model of
the signal processing
that we think occurs between
the cochlea and the midbrain
or the thalamus.
So you have the
bandpass filtering
that happens in the
cochlea, you get subbands,
you extract the instantaneous
amplitude in the envelopes,
and then you filter that again
with these modulation filters.
This is sort of a rough
understanding of the front end
of the auditory system.
And the question is, given
these representations,
how do we do the interesting
things that we do with sound?
So how do we recognize
things and their properties,
and do scene analysis,
and so on, and so forth.
And this is still
something that is still
very much in its infancy in
terms of our understanding.
One of the areas that
I've spent a bit of time
on to try to get a handle
on this is sound texture.
And I started working on this
because I sort of thought
it would be a nice way
in to understanding some
of these issues, and because
I gather that Eero was here
talking about visual textures.
I was asked to feature this, and
hopefully this will be useful.
So what are sound textures?
Textures are sounds that
result from large numbers
of acoustic events,
and they include things
that you hear all
the time, like rain--
[RAIN]
--or birds--
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
--or running water--
[RUNNING WATER]
--insects--
[INSECTS]
--applause--
[APPLAUSE]
--fire, so forth.
[FIRE BURNING]
OK.
So these are sounds
that they, typically,
are generated from large
numbers of acoustic events.
They're very common
in the world.
You hear these
things all the time.
But they've been
largely unstudied.
So there's been a long and
storied history of research
on visual texture,
and this really
had not been thought about very
much until a few years ago.
Now, a lot of the things that
people typically think about
in hearing are the
sounds that are
produced by individual events.
And if we have time, we'll
talk about this more later,
but stuff like this.
AUDIO: January.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: Or this.
[SQUEAK]
And these are the waveforms
associated with those events.
And the point is
that those sounds,
they have a beginning, and an
end, and a temporal evolution.
And that temporal
evolution is sort
of part of what makes the
sound what it is, right?
And textures are
a bit different.
So here's just
the sound of rain.
[RAIN]
Now of course, at some
point, the rain started
and hopefully at some
point it will end,
but the start and
the end are not
what makes it sound
like rain, right?
The qualities that make it
sound like rain are just there.
So the texture is stationary.
So the essential properties
don't change over time.
And so I got
interested in textures
because it seemed like
stationarity would make them
a good starting point
for understanding
auditory representation
because, in some sense,
it sort of simplifies
the kinds of things
you have to worry about.
You don't have to worry about
time in quite the same way.
And so the question that
we were interested in
is how people represent
and recognize texture.
So just to make that
concrete, listen to this.
[CHATTER]
And then this.
So it's immediately
apparent to you
that those are the same
kind of thing, right?
In fact, they're two different
excerpts of the same recording.
But the waveform itself is
totally different in the two
cases.
So there's something that
your brain is extracting
from those two excerpts
that tells you that they're
the same kind of thing, and
that, for instance, they're
different from this.
[BEES BUZZING]
So the question is, what is
it that you extract and store
about those waveforms that tells
you that certain somethings are
the same and other
things are different,
and that allows you to
recognize what things are?
And so the key
theoretical proposal
that we made in this work
is that because they're
stationary, textures
can be captured
by statistics that
are time averages
of acoustic measurements.
So the proposal is that when
you recognize the sound of fire,
or rain, or what
have you, you're
recognizing these statistics.
So what kinds of
statistics might we
be measuring if you think this
proposal has some plausibility?
And so part of the
reason for walking you
through this auditory model
is that whatever statistics
the auditory system
measures are presumably
derived from
representations like this,
right, that constitute the
input that your brain is getting
from the auditory periphery.
And so we initially
asked how far
one might get with
representations consisting
of fairly generic statistics
of these standard auditory
representations, things
like marginal moments
and correlations.
So the statistics
that we initially
considered were not, in any
way, specifically tailored
to natural sounds, and
really, ultimately,
what we'd like to do would be
to actually learn statistics
from data that, actually, we
think are good representations.
That's something
we're working on.
But these statistics are simple
and they involve operations
that you could
instantiate in neurons,
so it seemed like maybe
a reasonable place
to start to at least
get a feel for what
the landscape was like.
And so what I want
to do now is just
to give you some intuitions
as to what sorts of things
might be captured by statistics
of these representations.
And so at a minimum, to
be useful for recognition,
well, statistics need to
give you different values
for different sounds.
And so let's see what happens.
So let's first have a look
at what kinds of things
might be captured by marginal
moments of amplitude envelopes
from bandpass filters.
OK?
So remember, the
envelope, here, you
can think of as a stripe
through a spectrogram,
right, so it's the instantaneous
amplitude in a given frequency
channel.
So the blue thing
is the subband,
the red thing here
is the envelope.
And the marginal moments
will describe the way
the envelope is distributed.
So imagine you
took that red curve
and you collapsed that over
time to get a histogram that
tells you the
frequency of occurrence
of different amplitudes in that
particular frequency channel.
And that's what it looks like
for this particular example.
And you might think that,
well, this can't possibly
be all that informative,
right, because it's obviously
got some central
tendency and some spread,
but when you do this business
of collapsing across time,
you're throwing out all
kinds of information.
But one of the
interesting things
is that when you look at
these kinds of distributions
for different types
of sounds, you
see that they vary a fair
bit, and in particular,
that they're
systematically different
for a lot of natural sounds
than they are for noise signals.
So this is that same thing,
so it's this histogram here,
just rotated 90 degrees.
So we've got the
probability of occurrence
on the y-axis, and the
magnitude in the envelope of one
particular frequency
channel on the x-axis,
for three different recordings.
So the red plots what you
get for a recording of noise,
the blue is a stream, and the
green is a bunch of geese.
Geese don't quack.
Whatever the geese do.
AUDIENCE: Honk.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: Yeah, honking.
Yeah.
All right.
And this is a filter that's
centered at 2,200 Hertz.
In particular,
these examples were
chosen because the average
value of the envelope
is very similar in
the three cases.
But you can see that
the distributions
have very different shapes.
So the noise one, here, has
got pretty low variance.
The stream has got larger
variance, and the geese larger
still, and it's also
positively skewed.
So to got this kind
of long tail, here.
And if you look at the
spectrograms associated
with these sounds, you can
see where this comes from.
So spectogram of
noise is pretty gray,
so the noise signal
kind of hangs out
around its average
value most of the time,
whereas the stream has got
more gray and more black,
and the geese actually has
some white and some dark black.
So here, white would
correspond to down here,
black would
correspond to up here.
And the intuition here is that
natural signals are sparse.
In particular, they're
sparser than noise.
So we think of natural
signals as often being made up
of events like
raindrops, or geese
calls, and these
events are infrequent,
but when they occur they produce
large amplitudes in the signal.
And when they don't occur,
the amplitude is lower.
In contrast, the noise signal
doesn't really have those.
But the important
point about this
from the standpoint of
wanting to characterize
a signal with statistics is
that this phenomenon of sparsity
is reflected in some
pretty simple things
that you could compute
from the signal,
like the variance and the skew.
So you can see that the variance
varies across these signals,
as does a skew.
All right.
Let's take a quick
look at what you
might get by
measuring correlations
between these
different channels.
So these things also
vary across sound.
And you can see them in
the cochleogram here,
in this particular
example, as reflected
in these vertical streaks.
So this is the
cochleogram of fire,
and fire's got lots
of crackles and pops.
[FIRE BURNING]
And those crackles
and pops show up
as these vertical streaks
in the cochleogram.
So a crackle and pop is
like a click-like event.
Clicks have lots of different
frequencies in them,
and so you see these vertical
streaks in the spectrogram,
and that introduces
statistical dependencies
between different
frequency channels.
And so that can be measured
by just computing correlations
between the envelopes of
these different channels,
and that's reflected
in this matrix here.
So every cell of this
matrix is the correlation
between a pair of channels.
So we're going from
low frequencies,
here, to high, and low to high.
The diagonal has got to be
one, but the off-diagonal stuff
can be whatever.
You can see for example of
fire, there's a lot of yellow
and a lot of red, which
means that the amplitudes
of different channels
tends to be correlated.
But this is not the
case for everything.
So if you look at a water
sound, like a stream--
[STREAM]
--there are not very many
things that are click-like,
and most of the correlations
here are pretty close to zero.
So again, this is a
pretty simple thing
that you can measure, but
you get different values
for different sounds.
Similarly, if we look
at the power coming out
of these modulation filters,
you also see big differences
across sounds.
So that's plotted here for three
different sound recordings,
insects, waves, and a stream.
And so remember that
these modulation filters,
we think of them as being
applied to each cochlear
channel.
So the modulation power
that you would get from all
your modulation filters is--
you can see that in a 2D plot.
So this is the frequency
of the cochlear channel,
and this is the rate of
the modulation channel.
So these are slow modulations
and these are fast modulations.
And so for the
insects, you can see
that there are these,
like, little blobs up here.
And that actually
corresponds to the rates
at which the insects rub
their wings together and make
the sound that they
make, which kind of
gives it this shimmery quality.
[INSECTS]
In contrast, the waves
have got most of the power
here at very slow modulations.
[WAVES]
And the stream is
pretty broadband,
so there's modulations at a
whole bunch of different rates.
[STREAM]
All right.
So just by measuring the power
coming out of these channels,
we're potentially
learning something
about what's in the signal.
And I'm going to skip
this last example.
All right, so the
point is just that when
you look at these statistics,
they vary pretty substantially
across sound.
And so the question
we were interested in
is whether they could plausibly
account for the perception
of real world textures.
The key methodological
proposal of this work
was that synthesis is a
potentially very powerful way
to test a perceptual theory.
Now, maybe the kind
of standard thing
that you might
think that you might
try to do with this
type of representation
is measure these
statistics, and then
see whether, for
instance, you could
discriminate between different
signals or maybe [AUDIO OUT]..
And for various
reasons, I actually
think that synthesis
is potentially
a lot more powerful.
And the notion is this, that
if your brain is representing
sounds with some
set of measurements,
then signals that have the same
values of those measurements
ought to sound the same to you.
And so in particular, if we've
got some real world recording,
and we synthesize
a signal to cause
it to have the same
measurements, the statistics
in this case, as that
real world recording,
well, then the
synthetic signal ought
to sound like the
real world recording
if the measurements that
we use are like the ones
that the brain is using
to represent sound.
And so we can potentially
use synthesis,
then, to test a
candidate representation,
in this case, these statistics
that we're measuring,
are a reasonable representation
for the brain to be using.
So here's just a simple
example to kind of walk you
through the logic.
So let's suppose that you had
a relatively simple theory
of sound texture
perception, which
is that texture perception
might be rooted in the power
spectrum.
It's not so implausible.
Lots of people think
the power spectrum
is sort of a useful way to
characterize it [AUDIO OUT]..
And you might think that
it would have something
to do with the way
textures would sound.
And so in the context
of our auditory model,
the power spectrum is
captured by the average value
of each envelope.
Remember, the
envelope's telling you
the instantaneous amplitude,
and so if you just average that,
you're going to find out how
much power is in each frequency
channel.
So that's how you would
do it in this framework.
So the way this would work,
if you get some sound signal,
say, this--
[BUBBLES]
--you would pass it
through the model,
you'd measure the average
value of the envelope,
so you get a set of 30 numbers.
Say, if you have 30
bandpass filters there,
at the output of
each one of those,
you get the average of
all of the envelopes,
so you get 30 numbers.
And then you take
those 30 numbers
and you want to
synthesize the signal,
subject to the constraint
of it having the same value
for those 30 numbers.
And so in this case,
it's pretty simple to do.
So we take a noise
signal, we want
to start out as
random as possible,
so we take a noise signal,
we generate it's subbands,
and then we just scale
the subbands up or down
so that they have the
right amount of power.
And we add them back up, and
we get a new sound signal.
And then we listen to
it and we see whether it
sounds like the same thing.
OK?
Here's what they sound like.
And as you will hear, they just
sound like noise, basically,
right?
So this is supposed
to sound like rain--
[RAIN]
--or a stream--
[STREAM]
--or bubbles--
[BUBBLES]
--or fire--
[FIRE BURNING]
--or applause.
[APPLAUSE]
So you might notice that
they sound different, right?
And you might have even been
able to convince yourself,
well, that sounds a little
bit like applause, right?
So there's something there.
But the point is that they
don't sound anything like--
[APPLAUSE]
--or--
[FIRE BURNING]
--so on, and so forth.
OK?
All right, so the point
is that everything just
sounds like noise,
and so what this
tells us is that our
brains are not simply
registering the spectrum when
we recognize these textures.
Question is whether
additional simple statistics
will do any better.
And so we're going to
play the same game, right,
except we have a souped up
representation that's got
all these other things in it.
And so the
consequence of this is
that the process of
synthesizing something
is less straightforward.
So I was in Eero Simoncelli's
at the lab at the time,
and spent a while trying
to get this to work,
and eventually we got to work.
But conceptually, the
process is the same.
So you have some original
sound recording, rain,
or what have you, you pass it
through your auditory model,
and then you measure
some set of statistics.
And then you start out
with a noise signal,
you pass it through
the same model,
and then measure its statistics,
and those will in general
be different from
the target values.
And so you get some
error signal here,
and you use that error signal
to perform gradient descent
on the representation of the
noise in the auditory model.
And so you cause the
envelopes of the noise signal
to change in ways that cause
their statistics to move
towards the target value.
And there's a procedure here
by which this is iterated,
and I'm not going to
get into the details.
If you want to play
around with it,
there's a toolbox that's now
available on the lab website
if you want to do that,
and it's described
in more detail in that paper.
All right.
So the result, the
whole point of this,
is that we get a signal
that shares the statistics
of some real world sound.
How do they sound?
And remember, we're
interested in this
because if these statistics, if
this candidate representation
accounts for our perception
of texture, well,
then the synthetic signals
ought to sound like new examples
of the real thing.
And the cool thing,
and rewarding part
of this whole thing, is
that in many cases, they do.
So I'm just going to play
the synthetic versions.
All of these were
generated from noise,
just by causing the noise
to match the statistics
of, in this case, rain--
[RAIN]
--stream--
[STREAM]
--bubbles--
[BUBBLES]
--fire--
[FIRE BURNING]
--applause--
[APPLAUSE]
--wind--
[WIND BLOWING]
--insects--
[INSECTS]
--birds, oops--
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
--and crowd noise.
[CHATTER]
All right.
It also works for a lot
of unnatural sounds.
Here's rustling paper--
[RUSTLING PAPER]
--and a jackhammer.
[JACKHAMMER]
All right.
And so the cool
thing about this is
you can put it whatever
you want in there, right?
You can measure the
statistics from anything,
and you can generate something
that is statistically matched.
And when you do this
with a lot of textures,
you tend to get something
that captures some
of the qualitative properties.
And so the success
of this, and this
is in this case, the reason
why this is scientifically
interesting in
addition to fun, is
that it lends
plausibility to the notion
that these statistics could
underlie the representation
and recognition of textures.